Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for... FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning... hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
Moco-chan.
Did we screw that funny BAU BAU?
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Let's try again!
Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
HAJIMARU!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua!
I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for joining us for our 115th episode!
BAU BAU!
Why?
Why is the background like this right now?
We've been working all day long, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
All right!
Wow, the barkers had a lot of time to warm up.
But Ruffians, maybe you know you're just waking up.
Yeah!
So now it's time for you to wake up!
Okay!
BAU BAU!
It's just the way morning today!
Maybe that's the proper way to start the day today, huh?
Maybe it is!
It's the right paw, huh?
But what does the right paw mean?
Ruffians who are just joining us for the first time today!
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday!
AKA FUWAMOCO!
Hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's throw BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
It's a bit better.
Sometimes you know things are just a little bit funny, huh?
A little bit funny, huh?
BAU BAU!
We've reached the middle of our 3D week, Moco-chan!
Oh my gosh.
Only a couple days away, last one minute!
Moco-chan.
I think the Ruffians are awake.
They don't need any more alarms, okay?
Yeah, I'm alarmed.
BAU BAU!
Yeah, are you too?
But let's see, you know.
How are we gonna wake up today, huh?
Why don't we start with... Another Pero Sighting.
Popo?
Let's see where he is.
Again.
BAU BAU!
Well, it's okay I guess.
Next!
Oh!
Wow!
Ruffians!
Just now!
Really?
This just in?
Yeah.
Just a few minutes ago!
Wait, wait, wait, let me check.
Four minutes ago!
Let me check, let me check, let me check.
Let me check, let me check, let me check, let me check.
We need to confirm the news.
I will confirm the news.
Please wait momentarily.
We try to do our best with the resources we have.
Yes!
Ha.
Right!
It's amazing, Ruffians!
Congratulations, Nerissa!
You're making a new culture!
Yeah!
And, in my feelings, it's an EP.
It has four songs on it.
Four songs!
Say My Name.
Sweetest Scarlet.
In my feelings, the title song.
And Shadows.
Shatter.
Not shadow.
Love you.
Shatter.
Not shadow.
Yeah!
Yeah, four songs!
Four songs!
Yes!
Yeah!
And...
Well, maybe Ruffians, maybe FUWAMOCO.
We can see it.
We're lucky because, well, it launches on streaming services everywhere in your time zone at August 8th, midnight.
The moment it turns August 8th.
The moment it turns August 8th in your area, okay?
So look forward to it if it hasn't quite become midnight where you are.
Kota.
One more hour for you!
Soon!
I wanna listen to it now!
But we can't because we have FUWAMOCO Morning!
It's okay.
You know what we were thinking?
Maybe we can make all the Ruffians wait so we can listen to it, but... No.
That would be mean, right?
Please enjoy!
We definitely will.
That's the first thing we're doing after FUWAMOCO Morning is over.
We have something very exciting.
Wow.
And Ruffians, you have something exciting too!
Yeah!
But!
You know, EP is pretty exciting.
But also... Just as exciting is Nerissa's 3D debut!
It's coming up so soon!
It's gonna be happening on August 9th at 8pm PT.
It says three days here, but pretty much like two days now.
There's some, uh, feathers.
A little bit fluffy around the arms there.
Some stripes.
Yeah.
Shadows.
Well, I think we'll be able to see Nerissa even better on August 9th, so please make sure that you do.
Let's see her all lots and lots together with us.
Okay, Ruffians!
And then it's our turn.
We're so nervous!
BAU BAU!
Go get Nerissa!
Oh my gosh.
I'm so excited.
Yeah, you have it up, Ruffians.
You can listen after.
Or right now.
You know.
But I think it'd be better for you to just get the nice headphone.
Take a moment.
Listen to it deeply.
Right.
That's the way Nerissa would want you to listen to it.
Actually, Moco-chan!
Moco-chan, can I go get a cup of water right now?
What?
If I go get a cup of water, the barka will be even more rejuvenated.
And so will my ears.
Okay.
Moco-chan, you know why I wanna go get a cup of water?
Oh, for the water.
Oh.
I was confused.
Why do you need your ears, huh?
So I come and jubilate my ears with a nice fresh cup of Nerissa's EP!
Yeah.
Confusing me, huh?
Right?
And maybe the moment too.
BAU BAU!
Yeah.
Confused, huh?
We'll listen after maybe.
Maybe, yeah.
Nerissa's EP?
No.
The real EP1 is... Mococo!
Moco-chan.
BAU BAU!
Well, we have some very exciting news.
But today we also have some lonely news as well.
Our very precious senpai, Minato Akuma-senpai.
She announced that she'll be graduating on the 28th of August this month.
Ah, you know... It's really sad, you know, that she'll be leaving after six years of her whole life here.
But she's been a huge pillar to all of us and an amazing inspiration too.
Yeah.
We really love how cute and healing and just talented and skilled it is, AquaSempire!
Yes!
We really love her music too!
You know, she does lots and lots while we're in the cells.
Yeah.
And she also, you know, she's released a full visual novel too!
That's one of our huge dreams!
You know, and not to mention her solo lives too!
So many amazing things Akko-senpai has done!
You know, we really hope that even Akko-senpai has graduated, you know, that we can look
Her and all her accomplishments were inspiration and strength and growth for me too.
Thank you so much, Aqua-chan-pai!
We'll cheer for you until your final graduation concert comes to a close.
BAU BAU!
Let's enjoy the time together, okay?
We know what's tough, what is important.
Well, Ruffians.
What we wanted to talk about today?
August.
August, you know there's a lot of things going on in August.
A lot of goodbyes, but also summertime!
It's summer!
Yeah.
Which means...
Whole Summer.
BINGO!
Yes!
Yeah!
He's back.
Yeah, this year the main event is this Whole Summer BINGO!
BINGO!
Yeah!
We love bingo, right Ruffians?
Especially when there's fun and
Prizes.
Prizes?
Involved.
Yeah!
Wow.
Ruffians!
The rules are simple!
Yeah.
Ruffians, unfortunately, you can play along with us too, but I think it's more for the holo members than Ruffians, alright?
You probably won't get a prize.
We don't know what the prizes are yet, but we believe.
Let's take a look at the bingo rules!
Let's take a look at the rules.
Cause, they were explained in Japanese.
Visual stream the other day!
But there wasn't too much of an explanation in English as to what the whole bingo is about.
So we're gonna explain it!
So the whole summer bingo rules!
So there's a bingo card next to you.
We'll show you!
Bingo card!
And you fill the missions the square is in by completing the missions.
Yeah!
It's a bingo.
And you get one point for each bingo.
And you have from August 3rd until August 31st.
You have as in us.
Us.
To complete it!
And you can clear, as a FUWAMOCO, the missions in any way you'd like, you know?
So if you eat a watermelon, you can do a watermelon eating stream, eat a watermelon in a game, take a picture of a half-eaten watermelon.
It's not that tricky.
Not that complicated.
Not that intense.
But, uh, I say that now.
But let's take a look, you know?
Take a look at the PC.
Let's have fun.
Have fun.
This is the main bingo.
It's a bit hard to read, so we'll read it out.
Bento!
Eat a bento.
Have a bento.
Encounter a bento.
Play sports.
Play a sport?
Easy!
Next one is Summer Test of Courage, which might be confusing.
Something scary has to happen.
You have to test your courage.
And learn a new skill.
Learn a new skill.
Learn a new skill?
Anything.
I was thinking that I would like to try and see how far I can kick a shoe off my foot.
That!
I don't want to hit anyone, but that's learning a new skill, right?
Is it a skill?
What a skill.
Yeah.
Write a poetic verse.
Easy.
Flyin' from the sky.
Play a retro game.
Done.
Done!
We won!
We just, we said there was five yesterday!
And unfortunately that counts as a retro game.
It's a PS2 game!
I don't wanna say it's a retro game!
There's PS5 now.
I don't wanna count.
I don't want it to count.
PS5 exists.
Talk about some men of his own.
Conduct an experiment.
On the Ruffians.
Moco-chan.
Well.
Organizing events.
It's something you've never tried before.
Conducting investigation.
On the Ruffians.
How is it different from experiment?
Experiment is different.
It's trying something.
Okay.
Investigation.
Serious business.
Okay.
Back again!
Memorize all 47 prefectures of Japan!
Could that have anything to do with... I wonder.
We might be doing a stream kinda like that one.
And then there's the free space!
Your summer goals!
FUWAMOCO Abyssgard.
Next is watch a movie!
Moco-chan, you're supposed to fill it with your summer goals!
Watch a movie!
Yeah, it's too difficult.
Start a picture diary.
Eniki.
Bijou.
Do a leisure activity.
This is a hard one.
What's a leisure activity?
We'll see!
Catch insects or fish.
I want to do both!
I keep on looking around everywhere.
Is there a cicada I can catch?
She keeps on telling me, Moco-chan, we have to catch some insects.
Okay!
Next is treat your parents.
Very important.
After that, have a collab.
Done?
Ruffians!
Does this count as a collab right now?
Technically, yes.
Yes?
No?
No!
What?
Doesn't count!
We'll see, okay?
Fan service.
Skip.
Sing a summery song!
What?
Scaming off!
Okay, done.
Confess your sins.
Skip the fanservice one.
Write a letter!
Okay, we write letters all the time.
Give a gift?
Okay.
Find or show a treasure.
Pretty simple.
We're working on it.
Already got some done!
Yeah.
But you know, this is the Holo Summer Bingo.
But this is not just the only one.
There is Inferno Bingo.
Inferno.
So what is Inferno Bingo?
Inferno Bingo is new!
We have a bunch of very infernal, difficult tasks here.
And these ones are actually determined by us Holo members!
Yeah!
Yeah, we all suggested a bunch!
FUWAMOCO!
They suggested...
Wash a dog.
Yeah.
And bungee jumping!
But we don't remember.
We didn't get told.
Yeah.
We didn't remember suggesting them.
What did we suggest?
And they were like... Oh my god!
That's right!
Yeah, so we were like, oh!
What did Fuwamoco suggest?
I can't remember anymore.
Wash a dog would've been nice, huh?
Moco-chan, I could've just gotten you into the bathtub and... Check!
Right.
Twitter space in the bathtub.
Done!
Well.
Missed opportunity.
Can't do that anymore.
No.
Yeah.
But the good thing about Inferno Bingo is that one bingo counts for three times the points of a regular one.
So.
Inferno Bingo, good.
But we have two waiting for call streams, like a call-in stream with a set theme.
Lots of ideas.
And then we have sent a long message of love to a hololive member.
To be honest, I feel like we sort of do this often.
Create a new unit.
Ideas.
Successfully pull off a prank.
We can do that.
Advent.
We're innocent, though.
Yeah.
Feel free to decide for yourself.
Free space.
Anything.
Yeah.
Collab with members I don't usually interact with.
Unfortunately, that's... We've only been around for one year.
There's a lot of senpai we haven't collabed with, so... Unfortunately, this one's not too tricky, right?
Do a stream of impersonating other hololive members!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Can't you say it in your voice?
I can't, I can't.
I can.
Make Italian food.
Last one!
Try eating insects.
Why do they say try, not just eat insects?
Wait, so we have to catch insects.
And then we have to eat.
Oh!
We'll see.
I wonder what we'll find.
What will the harvest be like?
Well, like we said, our goal is to get every single one of them done.
They now have completely cleared both the normal bingo and the infernal bingo.
And that both of us, you know, FUWAMA complete!
Moco-chan complete!
Exactly!
So that's a lot of fun to be half Ruffians!
But like the rules said, it goes up until August 31st.
Which means, really, we only have half of the month to do this before breaking the mansion.
Yeah...
We're gonna do our best for FUWAMOCO!
One thing for sure is... We're gonna have a lot of fun together with you!
BAU BAU!
Let's see which one we get complete.
Yeah.
We'll see.
BAU BAU!
We'll update it on Twitter, okay?
Also on the community page where we get big updates.
Yeah.
Full bingo.
BAU BAU!
And that's the hololive summer bingo!
You understand the bingo?
It's not that tricky.
I think Beii-senpai is doing it.
Beii-senpai won last year though.
Right?
How do we beat her, Moco-chan?
I don't know.
Could I have the bingo?
We'll have to do our best!
BAU BAU!
You understand?
Does it have to be all on stream?
It doesn't!
It doesn't.
Necessarily.
No.
You can upload like a photo, like a set of watermelons.
Yeah!
To Twitter, so like, or do it in a game.
So like Italian food, technically you can make the Italian food off stream, take a photo of it, and then be like, I made Italian food!
Yeah!
And that's clear, right?
Clear.
Done.
I know.
I think it depends on everybody.
What's possible for them?
Games do count!
It says eat a watermelon.
And it says you can eat a watermelon in a game.
I'm smoking some heroin.
Make it off-collab with Daora.
But what if Daora ends up having just off-collab months when she only makes Italian food with all the food?
Right!
Wow.
She'll be a chef.
Chef daora.
Yeah!
Alright.
Doyoshi!
BAU BAU!
There's a lot to look forward to!
But, it's the middle of the week.
You know, it's...
Summertime is hotter, you know, maybe you're feeling a little bit beaten down.
Or a little bit drained.
Yeah.
Huh?
Moco-chan.
Do you have anything to bring us back up to full energy, full power?
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
It's that day of the week!
It's time for another one of my Mococo Pup Talks!
And you're gonna hear it straight from me.
Mococo!
Ruffians.
Has it been a little bit rough recently?
No.
Maybe you're feeling a bit more emotional than usual.
And it's okay to feel like that, Ruffians.
It's perfectly normal and understandable, so don't beat yourself up for that.
It's important to remember that nothing in life is permanent, and that's exactly why things are special to us.
You know, just like a sunny day or blooming flowers.
Don't be sad for what you've lost, but be happy for the good times that we've had, for all the memories that were made,
Please remember that even though things might not be as they were, that there are good times ahead of you for sure.
Okay?
I can promise that.
You just might not know yet.
And it's fine to be sad for now.
You can take that time.
But make sure to notice all the happy things going on around you during that time as well, so you don't miss them.
And continue to make good memories during this time too.
Remember, we're all here to support each other.
Got it?
Ganbatte ne!
BAU BAU!
Let's do our best to keep our feelings.
I know what I feel like right now.
I feel like I could be the Doggie of the Day after that.
But I'm not.
Let's see who the Doggie of the Day is today!
The Doggie of the Day is... De-den!
It's Kobe!
Kobe!
Such a sweet, quirky... Look at that tongue!
That is the tongue.
Bubblegum tongue.
Look at the... The cheeks?
Eyebrows!
But he has the... The fluffy cheeks!
I just love the muscles!
I do like the eyebrows.
They look like coal mines.
A coal mine is silly, but it has a heart of gold!
I can see it!
I can see how shining that heart is!
Cute!
How does it call me?
BAU-BAU!
Thank you, Sora.
Sora is silly, but Sora is sweet!
BAU-BAU!
I love it!
A fatal attitude!
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
Kobe!
Kobe is just about the bestest boy ever!
Just about.
Amazing smile!
Loves you no matter what!
Even if you don't have any traits.
Shiori too!
Shiori!
BAU BAU!
I love the cheeks.
My ears are so big now.
BAU BAU!
And next!
Ruffians, have you been having some summer adventures?
Let's take a look at where you've been at!
Today, I went on a walk!
We have... De-den!
Oh!
Malfuji!
Wait, you climbed on Malfuji!
Together with a Ruffian buddy too!
Yeah!
That makes us so happy!
Wow wow!
Not just that, you took us for the climb too!
Right!
All together!
Thank you!
One of our dreams came true then!
We'd really love to climb Mount Fuji ourselves one day too!
BAU BAU!
Make sure you get a lot of rest okay!
Rest, rest, rest, rest!
BAU BAU!
Amazing.
You have to be careful on those kind of trips though too.
Safety.
BAU BAU!
And next!
Moco-chan, did we get a question?
For the Question of the Day, we have... DE-DEN!
Well, I know Pero is nasty.
Nasty.
But his birthday is coming up.
So, question other than putting, what would Pero like for a present?
Has Fuwamoco got him a present?
Did we forget his birthday last year?
He doesn't hold grudges.
Why?
Grudges, maybe.
We'll see.
But you know, I think Pero, what he wants more is for people to know that he exists, you know?
He's been missing for so long.
So, uh, maybe he's got a bit self-conscious about that.
That's just my guess though, okay?
But for gifts other than pudding!
Why not get him some clothing or accessories or something?
I hope I don't have to wear this big thing!
I'm sure he would love that!
Pero would love that.
Oh!
A bikini.
A bunch of steaks?
Can you wear those steaks though?
A big bow-tie of steak.
What?
Hamburgers!
I thought we were talking about clothing.
Is he gonna wear steaks?
I don't know.
But you know, Ruffians, more than anything, it's the thought that counts, right?
So don't worry about him.
Yeah, the thought.
You know, like, if you don't think of anything,
That means the most.
Huh?
This Pero's nasty.
BAU BAU!
Yeah.
But let's forget about that!
I wanna say a big thank you to all the Mofins!
Thank you for always being a huge part of FUWAMOCO Morning here with us!
Please remember, if you have a question, if you know you wanna show the world just how cute your dog is, it's gonna be the dog of the day.
Your amazing walk.
Please use the hashtag #FWMCMORNING, okay?
Got it!
BAU BAU!
Bye bye!
And for our next stream, we have de-den!
Portal 2!
Our first time!
Finally!
It's a co-op game, that means we have to cooperate.
Hopefully that will go well because I heard there's a lot of hard puzzles.
We'll see how this goes.
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
I don't know if we take a look at our schedule.
Yeah!
Wow, we have some other things.
After 4.02 we have the 47 Perfections Learning Stream.
Yeah, we're gonna do our best and maybe we'll get some help from some JP Ruffians who know a little bit better the map of Japan, maybe?
Yeah.
And then we have Nerissa's 3D debut!
Yeah!
On Friday, August 9th at 8 p.m.
PT.
Don't forget!
Yeah, don't forget.
And then we have, on the very next day, our 3D debut at 8 p.m.
PT.
Everything that we worked so so so hard for, all the practice, all the tears, all the sweat, everything goes into this one big day.
I hope I can sleep.
Please be there, my friends.
Please be there to cheer us on and BAU BAU BAU!
It's okay!
BAU BAU!
And then, afterwards, on the very next day at 6pm PT, we will be having a big afterparty for a 3D showcase!
Please, please let us talk to you about all the stuff we've been doing, all the practice, what we did, this and that, and all.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so, so much, Ruffians!
Thank you for being here to say hello and start your day off on the right paw again together with us.
Before we say bau bau for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today and we'd also like to share
The FUWAMOCO boys with the Ruffians joining us through the archive today!
It's BAU BAU BINGO!
As for our Extra Special Ruffians!
Gengen!
BAU BAU!
Mopomoro!
Seiman!
BAU BAU!
Zane!
Kajun Bowser.
BAU BAU!
Our Destiny.
Dog Salmon.
BAU BAU!
Jonathan.
Sushi Tricks.
BAU BAU!
Cure Neckbeard.
Patient Zero.
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!